[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hop hop hop je suis bien content les
enfants propos tombent
allons-y gaiement nounours bon pour
prolonger mon
allons vers la terre je suis bien
content de voir un petit jeu on
[Musique]
poux
bonsoir
mes caprices la poupée de pas preneur
oui elle est terrible elle était
convenable aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'elle s'appelle caprices
ça y est il ferme les yeux vo sam 9
bonsoir auprès d'elle
bonsoir corniche au peuple annonce
aux doubiens bonsoir magie l'état
on a des soucis pas prodl
qu'il dit
voilà comment moi je renonce même
coucher ça m'endort d'endormir les bébés
via vais vous chanter une berceuse
[Musique]
vous devriez c'est
moi c'est la fin de la journée
c'est le moment de se coucher
nous faisons pas
nos amis ils s'en vont tous les
noms et allongeant c'est
sûr sans nuage j'en suis certain le
marchand de sable vient
il nous dira
fermez vos yeux et dormait tous les deux
nous sommes bien dans notre lit
99 fouette avoir nui sa grosse voix me
fait plaisir quand je vais m'endormir
quand je vais m'endormir
sa foi nous faire plaisir
[Musique]
caprice d'or
cornichons si
de nuit les enfants
à demain
bonne nuit de noces bonne nuit juilletà
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
nous pouvons partir pas trop
dorment tous connus des enfants
embrasser bien fort vous par an
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette de
bien vous laver les dents le feu de pur
[Musique]
oh
e
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]